we once bought over a thousand VHS tapes
for twenty dollars I saw like a pink
sign for a garage sale on the way to my
parents so I pull up one big cardboard
sign and the sign says VHS a dollar each
it's like 1998.99 so eBay isn't like
super known yet but I know that I know I
can look it up when I get home I go to
the guy how much do you want for all of
them he's like all of them give me a
hundred bucks but of course you're like
I go nah I'm like thank you so much like
I really appreciate it goes make me an
offer I go look I don't really want to
schlep this I don't even know if I have
enough room in my car I'm like I'll give
you 20 bucks he goes no way I'm like I
understand I'm like have a great day we
start walking back he goes yo take it I
go to pay him and he's like my wife
would have killed me if I packed these
all back up but I don't want to pack it
up we take them home me and AJ go
upstairs to the desktop computer and the
first tape we take out is like a teeny
bopper movie with Justin Timberlake from
NSYNC and we type it in and it's sold
for 28 and I'm sitting there and I'm
like this one tape and literally right
this second as I'm telling you the story
there's like 800 VHS tapes in my parents
attic